the princess Elettra Marconi the
daughter of gooli Elmo Marconi stopped
here at MIT to talk to us a bit about
her father in his accomplishments her
father was a Nobel Prize winner in 1909
for his work on wireless telegraphy his
wish was since I was very young to
transmit with electric waves it was
always making experiments building his
equipment with his own hands trying and
trying again and this is why he is a
great example for the young ones because
he had great willpower and 21 years old
he succeeded in sending signals across
the hill near Bologna l he bought this
beautiful yacht that he named electra
and when I was born he called me like
his yacht and on bother you after letra
he made inventions of the radar that he
was calling blind navigation and then
the parabolic antenna is the beginning
of satellite Neil Armstrong when we met
him my mother and I said if it wasn't
for your father for your husband I would
have never gone in the moon at one of
their plan or buy a pre-prepared
part of her mission is to inspire young
people to go into the sciences to pursue
technology and to really go after doing
something with their lives that will
make the world a better place his love
of boating and of the ocean and a
sailor's really motivated him largely to
come up with this method of transmitting
messages while you're at sea my father
was invited on board the Titanic but
luckily he he didn't except there was
why I was telegraph on that ship they
were able to signal for help and in the
middle of the ocean a generation before
the people of those lifeboats would have
been adrift in the ocean and no one
could have known no one could know that
they were there those who lived lived
because of guglielmi Marconi's invention
his great joy was when he met the
survivors in the hub of new york he went
towards them and they were so thankful
grateful to him they were embracing him
kissing him that was the greatest reward